c'est une
machine russe excellence monsieur
abdallah chahid président de la 66ème
session de
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
je tient d'emblée à vous féliciter à
l'occasion de votre élection à la
présidence de cette session de
l'assemblée générale
je vous souhaite les plein succès dans
l'exercice de vos fonctions
je tiens aussi à remercier le secrétaire
général monsieur antonio guterres rech
pour les efforts qu'ils déploient
dans le cadre de son mandat afin de
satisfaire aux aspirations des états
membres conformément à la charte des
nations unies monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs
ces deux dernières années le monde a
connu
des heures sans précédent
les hôpitaux ont atteint leur pleine
capacité des millions de vies humaines
ont été perdues les économies se sont
contractés la pauvreté et la faim ont
explosé des villes ont été confinés des
couvre feux ont été imposées des
universités des écoles ont fermé leurs
portes
et soudain nous avions peur de nous
approcher les uns des autres tout cela
du fait d'un virus invisible un virus
qui continue d'évoluer de muter menaçant
de faire toujours plus de victimes au
travers de par le monde
en dépit de ces difficultés
une lueur d'espoir est apparue
des efforts extraordinaires ont été
déployés
des avancées médicales remarquables ont
été enregistrés sans parler des gestes
de solidarité humaine
dans de nombreuses pays dans leurs
relations cependant
certains ont utilisé la pandémie pour
régler des comptes politiques accusant
d'autres pays d'avoir créé le virus
d'autres en quarts ignorait égoïstement
les besoins d'autrui
choisissant de croire qu'ils étaient
seuls sur cette terre
pire encore
d'aucuns ont tiré parti de la pandémie
pour intensifier les mesures économiques
coercitives unilatérales imposées au
pays à ceux qui n'étaient pas d'accord
avec eux en dépit des conséquences
humanitaires catastrophique de ces
mesures
ils ont fait la sourde oreille aux
appels répétés de l'onu et des agences
humanitaires
qui demandait à ce que ces mesures
soient levés
si la copie de 19 a pu tuer une personne
en l'absence de sanction imaginé avec
des sanctions comme le rapporte
rapporteur spécial sur les conséquences
des mesures coercitives unilatérales sur
la jouissance des êtres humains l'a dit
et je cite les sanctions sèment la mort
la souffrance dans les pays tels que
cuba l'iran le soudan la syrie le
venezuela yeux l'hymen fin de citation
tel que l'a relevé un groupe d'experts
indépendants de l'onu en matière de
droits humains
et je le cite les sanctions imposées au
nom des droits humains
tu en fait et prive
les peuples de leurs droits
fondamentaux le droit notamment à la
santé à l'alimentation à la vie fin de
citation
nous félicitons du thème de la 76 ème
session de l'assemblée générale
à savoir miser sur l'espoir pour
renforcer la résilience
néanmoins je m'interroge
est-ce que cet appel sera entendu
de chacun et de chacune
est-ce que la
reconstruction sera durable est ce que
les droits des peuples seront respectés
les enseignements du passé seront ils
pris en compte certains gouvernements
ont ils renoncé à leur politique
défectueuses qui ont menacé la sécurité
à la stabilité internationale
ces questions
appellent des réponses claires et
déterminées
si nous ne voulons pas que le thème de
ce débat général ne demeure qu'un slogan
pour les médias et
les politiques sans avoir de réel effet
dans le monde
monsieur le président
ne savait que trop bien que la syrie a
été un des pays les plus touchés par le
terrorisme et les crimes terroristes
des crimes rendue possible grâce
au soutien financier médiatique
logistique offertes par les pays qui
parrainent le terrorisme
nous avons subi moult tragédie alors que
les terroristes tué déplaçait des
innocents détruisaient les
infrastructures piller les ressources de
la syrie créant une crise humanitaire
dans un pays qui a tant de raisons
d'être fiers de lui ayant
atteint un niveau de développement
plus de 9,5 pour cent avant le début de
la guerre terroriste contre la syrie
grâce au sacrifice de notre peuple de
nos forces armées avec le soutien
précieux de nos alliés de nos amis nous
avons réussi à avancer dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme est sur la voie de
son éradication
l'histoire n'oubliera pas que les
syriens
se sont défendus eux mêmes et leur pays
mais ont défendu le monde tout entier
contre le terrorisme le ciel la série
confirme qu'elle poursuivra ce noble
combat
jusqu'à ce que soit éradiquée de notre
terre l'ensemble des terroristes je
serais ce que nous ayons rétablir
l'autorité de l'état sa sécurité sa
stabilité
il s'agit là d'une obligation nationale
et constitutionnelles et d'un droit non
négociable
nous n'abandonnerons n'abandonneront pas
la partie indépendamment des pressions
extérieures
peu importe les mensonges et les
accusations prononcées à notre endroit
pour ceux qui continuent de soutenir
les terroristes
d'investir dans les terroristes nous
tenons à leur dire qu'ils sont voués à
l'échec
tôt ou tard
ce soutien accordé au terrorisme
reviendra les hanter ce sont les
innocents qui payeront le prix comme
cela est le cas dans un certain nombre
de pays nous devons donc veiller à ce
que cette tragédie soit évité à cet
égard il semblerait qu'une personne qui
ait pris la parole à cette tribune il ya
quelques jours continuent d'être
totalement détaché de la réalité se
berçant de l'illusion de pouvoir revenir
en arrière
pensant que son argent pourra couvrir
ses crimes leur échec que continue
d'investir dans le terrorisme en syrie
permettra à ses maîtres de réaliser
leurs desseins
monsieur le président
la syrie a participé avec sérieux de
manière positive au processus d'astana
dans l'espoir qu'ils contribuaient à la
lutte contre le terrorisme et à la
sécurité à la stabilité du pays
cependant le régime turc a montré à
maintes et maintes reprises
qu'il n'était pas attaché au au
processus d'astana ou aux accords de
sotchi sur id lit dans le nord-ouest de
la syrie au lieu de cela ils continuent
de soutenir de protéger les groupes
terroristes qui opèrent dans la région
en particulier le front elle nous sera
désigné entité terroriste par le conseil
de sécurité
c'est ainsi que la région est devenue un
incubateur pour les terroristes
étrangers tel que confirmé par les
rapports de différents comités du
conseil de sécurité
par ailleurs
le régime turc a commis et continuent de
commettre des crimes de guerre des
crimes contre l'humanité dans les
territoires syriens qu'elle occupe au
travers de la turquie za sion de
politique de changement démographique
contrat par le biais de déplacement ou
de répression collective en coupant
l'approvisionnement en eau de plus de 1
million de syriens dassa cas
et dans les villes voisines
ajoutez à cela que le régime turc a
réduit le niveau de l'eau de l'euphrate
qui atteint la moitié des niveaux
convenu entre les deux pays en 1987
il en a résulté une situation
humanitaire grave sans parler des
conséquences écologiques sanitaires et
agricoles tous ces violations tous ces
crimes exige une action urgente et
sérieuse du conseil de sécurité
et du secrétariat
ces actions doivent cesser immédiatement
monsieur le président nous répétons que
toute présence étrangère sur sol syrien
sans le consentement du gouvernement
syrien est illégale et constitue une
violation flagrante du droit
international et de la charte des
nations unies
violation de toutes les résolutions du
conseil de sécurité réaffirmant
l'importance du respect de la
souveraineté de l'indépendance de
l'unité et de l'intégrité territoriale
de la syrie
cette présence monsieur le président
fait ce fait obstacle aux efforts de
lutte contre le terrorisme menace la
stabilité la sécurité de la région ainsi
les forces turques et américaine
continuent d'occuper les territoires de
la syrien sous de faux prétextes
clients les ressources naturelles du
peuple syrien
ces forces doivent sans prérequis
cesser
d'agir tout comme nous avons réussi à
éliminer les terroristes de l'essentiel
de la série nous nous efforcerons de
mettre un terme à l'occupation avec la
même détermination utilisant tous les
moyens possibles en droit international
l'histoire a montré que la syrie tôt ou
tard repousse toujours ses occupants
quant aux à ceux qui cherchent la
sécession dans le nord-est de la syrie
nous les mettons en garde contre cette
illusion qui va à l'encontre de la
volonté du peuple syrien
en poursuivant ses objectifs
il se rallie à ceux qui complotent
contre l'unité de la syrie et nous leur
ferons front comme il se doit ils
doivent se départir de leurs illusions
et tirer les enseignements de l'histoire
récente
favoriser les forces d'occupation
extérieurs aux dépens de leur peuple est
vouée à l'échec ne fera que le ramener
humiliations et nuire à leur pays à leur
peuple
s'il
se considère comme faisant partie du
peuple syrien
monsieur le président parallèlement à la
lutte contre le terrorisme le
gouvernement syrien a toujours été
ouvert aux initiatives politiques
authentiques impartial qui visent à nous
permettre de venir à bout de cette crise
une crise
qui a frappé le peuple syrien et l'état
syrien en dépit les obstacles érigés par
les des pays qui n'ont aucun intérêt à
voir l'instabilité revenir en syrie
nous restons inébranlable dans notre
attachement aux principes sur lesquels
repose notre nation mais nous avons
participé aux pourparlers de genève au
consultation de moscou réunis dastan
altana nous avons facilité la
convocation du comité constitutionnel
en aidant à trouver un accord sur sa
composition et son règlement intérieur à
cet égard nous réitérons que ce
processus doit être
menée par les syriens
piloté par les syriens sans ingérence
extérieure quelle qu'elle soit
la constitution et toutes les questions
connexes
relève des droits exclusifs des syriens
et seuls les syriens peuvent se
prononcer
je souligne aussi
l'importance pour l'envoyé spécial de la
syrie de se concentrer sur son rôle de
facilitateur et doit faire rapport de
ses travaux de manière honnête
impartiale et objective
monsieur le président
nous n'avons eu de cesse de répéter que
les portes de la syrie sont grandes
ouvertes aux réfugiés souhaitant revenir
en toute sécurité de manière volontaire
dans leur pays toutes les institutions
compétentes de syrie oeuvrent sans
relâche
dans ce sens en rebâtissant les
infrastructures les services dans les
zones récupéré aux terroristes en
instaurant les processus nécessaires
pour faciliter le retour de la
population et satisfaire à ses besoins
les plus fondamentaux
à cet effet un certain nombre de décrets
ont été publiés
lesquels devraient contribuer au retour
en toute sécurité et volontaires de
notre peuple malheureusement alors que
le gouvernement syrien et ses alliés
consentent des efforts sincères sur le
front humanitaire
d'aucuns tire parti des souffrances
infligées aux syriens pour servir des
visées qui n'ont rien à voir avec les
but humanitaire ou les intérêts des
syriens
à cet égard
je me dois de souligner l'importance que
l'action humanitaire en syrie respecte
la souveraineté l'unité et l'intégrité
territoriale de la syrie elle doit être
menée en coordination avec le
gouvernement syrien avec son
consentement dans le droit fil de la
résolution 46 marc oblique 142 de
l'assemblée générale
nous demandons aussi à ce soit élargi la
portée des interventions humanitaires
pour englober l'aide au développement
les projets de résilience de relèvement
rapide englobant notamment l'eau
l'assainissement la santé les services
médicaux et d'hébergement nous sommes
prêts à tout mettre en oeuvre pour
garantir l'accès humanitaire aux
bénéficiaires en syrie le mécanisme des
deux transfrontières doit disparaître
suite des incidents de corruption et
d'incidents des incidents
impliquant notamment le détournement de
l'aide vers les groupes terroristes
plutôt que les populations qui ont
réellement besoin monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs
la république arabe syrienne souligne
une fois encore que l'emploi d'armes
chimiques est répréhensible et
totalement inacceptable quelles que
soient les circonstances par qui que ce
soit où que ce soit quand que ce soit
telle est la position de la syrie c'est
la raison pour laquelle la syrie a
volontairement accéder la convention sur
les armes chimiques
et s'est acquitté de toutes les
obligations
connexes en un temps record tout en
continuant de coopérer sachant que
certains pays continuent de conserver ce
type d'armes depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale
certains de ces pays sont présents dans
cette salle alors que je vous parle
la syrie continue de coopérer avec le ja
c'est pour régler cette question dans
les plus brefs délais malheureusement
donc certains pays
cherchent à politiser cette question
ils ont lancé les accusations sans
fondement contre la syrie
invoquant des informations émanant de
terroristes et de leurs soutiens
ne fait pas les surprises
il utilise aussi
des rapports
dénués de toute crédibilité des rapports
diffusés sur internet
vous savez pleinement qui diffuse ces
renseignements sur internet il hausse
ils ont tous six
interprètes et à leur guise les
dispositions de la convention sur les
armes chimiques pour créer des
mécanismes illicites et imposer une
les ions aux pays occidentaux contre la
cire et la 25e session la conférence des
états parties à la convention sur les
armes chimiques et sajjad un précédent
dangereux pour l'organisation est une
menace pour toutes les parties monsieur
le président
depuis 1967 israël continue d'occuper
une partie du territoire syrien qui nous
est cher le goal en des hauteurs du
golan la république arabe syrienne
demeure engagé et déterminé à exercer
son droit de récupérer le golan syrien
occupé pour venir jusqu'aux lignes du 4
juin 1967
toutes les décisions et les mesures
prises par israël puissance occupante
afin de modifier les caractéristiques
naturelles et démographique de la région
afin d'imposer les l'oise et
l'administration
d'israël sont nuls et non avenus n'ont
aucun effet en droit international et en
vertu des résolutions pertinentes de
l'onu notamment la résolution 497 de
il est inacceptable que l'onu et la
communauté internationale
ne parviennent pas à contraindre israël
à appliquer ces résolutions et à faire
en sorte qu'elles cessent les violations
systématiques et graves du droit
international humanitaire et du droit
international des droits de l'homme
israël continue de multiplier ses
colonies de soutenir les terroristes
israël persécute
discrimine détient de manière arbitraire
les syriens sous-occupation pillent les
ressources naturelles du goal ans et
viols à maintes reprises la souveraineté
syrienne
ainsi donc israël doit être tenu
comptable de ce comportement de voyou
nous devons faire en sorte qu israël ne
puisse pas jouir de l'impunité c'est
important il en va de la sécurité la
stabilité de la région nova de la
justice et du droit international en
dépit
de ce que nous vivons ces dernières
années en syrie la cause palestinienne
demeure une priorité pour la syrie la
syrie qui a tout mis en oeuvre pour
soutenir nos frères et soeurs de
palestine dans le cadre de la lutte pour
récupérer les territoires occupés pour
retrouver leurs droits légitimes
notamment le droit établir un état
indépendant sur le territoire avec
jérusalem comme capitale
le droit à devenir membre de plein droit
de l'onu ainsi que le droit des réfugiés
palestiniens de retrouver leur terre
d'origine en le respect du droit
international et des résolutions
pertinentes de l'onu
nous demandons aussi à ce qu'il soit mis
un terme aux crimes de guerre et crimes
contre l'humanité perpétrés par israël
dans les territoires palestiniens
occupés notamment les assassinats les
activités de peuplement les tati de
sièges la détention arbitraire et
déplacements forcés la discrimination
raciale
la syrie tient pour responsables les
pays qui soutiennent israël dans ces
crimes monsieur le président la syrie
soutient pleinement et est solidaire de
la république islamique d'iran face aux
mesures américaines illégales y est
responsable qui lui sont imposées
notamment suite au retrait par les états
unis de l'accord sur le nucléaire le psg
s'est à cet égard la syrie condamne le
blocus économique imposé à cuba depuis
des décennies et la militarisation
américaine de la situation dans la
péninsule coréenne
ont pays
demande aussi à ce qu'il soit mis un
terme au terrorisme économique imposé
par les états unis et ses alliés
occidentaux au venezuela à l'iran au
bélarus au nicaragua rpdc ainsi qu'à mon
pays la syrie dans le respect du droit
international et des résolutions de
l'onu à cet égard
je me dois aussi de soutenir les efforts
de la russie de la chine pour défendre
le droit international maintenir la
sécurité et la stabilité et promouvoir
le développement de par le monde face
aux politiques hégémoniques et aux
tentatives d'ingérence de certains pays
monsieur le président en conclusion
nous devons promouvoir le dialogue et la
compréhension
entre nous sur la base du respect mutuel
de l'intérêt commun de l'égalité
souveraine et du respect du droit
international
ceci est indispensable si nous voulons
faire émerger un ordre mondial plus
équilibrée plus démocratique plus juste
qui contribue à satisfaire les
aspirations communes au peuple
au développement la prospérité la
stabilité
tout ceci nous devons le faire
en défiant les gouvernements qui
poursuivent leur ingérence militaire
politiques soutiennent le terrorisme
emploi des mesures coercitives
unilatérales en violation des valeurs
de l'humanité les principes de la charte
certains doivent comprendre que nous
vivons dans un seul et même monde
interconnecté qu aucun pays ne peut
servir ses intérêts garantir sa sécurité
aux dépens des intérêts de la sécurité
d'autrui merci
enfin que ministre je remercie le
ministre des affaires étrangères et des
expatriés de la république arabe
syrienne de son intervention
je donne maintenant la parole
aux représentants de l'islande afin
qu'ils présentent une intervention du
ministre
mr président monsieur le président j'ai
l'honneur de